let's talk about artificial intelligence
we gave birth
to a i ai
when you think of ai you might think of
this kind of thing open the pod bay
doors
i'm sorry dave
i'm afraid i can't do that but ai is no
longer science fiction it's everywhere
from the algorithms that suggest what
videos or music you might like to
predictive text to the chat bot
answering your banking inquiry ai is
becoming almost like electricity you
know it's just something that's going to
become ubiquitous we don't recognize the
extent to which our lives are being
altered by the technology that is being
permitted so what exactly is ai why are
many countries trying to figure out a
way to control it and could it already
be too late
[Music]
artificial intelligence essentially
means building computer systems that can
solve problems and think in the way that
humans do
but beyond that big idea in practice ai
can mean a lot of different things
intelligence very broadly defined is the
ability to achieve complex goals
and artificial intelligence is just that
but then not by humans but by machines
such as computers ai is a huge field and
within it there are many different
approaches that try to replicate human
style decision making but probably the
main one is what's called machine
learning it's the idea that a computer
algorithm can learn from data recognize
patterns and make decisions
with little or no human interference if
you think about traditional computer
programs you're essentially giving the
computer an instruction manual for how
to carry out a particular task
but with machine learning the algorithm
effectively creates the instruction
manual itself and it can continuously
adjust those instructions to get better
at what it's designed to do
take google maps for example it uses
machine learning to combine real-time
data about traffic conditions with
historical data to generate super
accurate predictions for how long your
trip might take
and the more it does this the better it
gets at it
[Music]
now ai technology has been around for
decades
but in the last 10 years it's really
taken off for a couple of reasons
computers are kind of doubling in power
every two years and this has been going
on for decades now and so we got to the
point where we had really fast computers
we also had
lots and lots of data more data than
ever before really the last decade or so
has been probably the most consequential
period in artificial intelligence today
we're at the point where ai is being
applied in almost every sector
even on this show
we use ai software to transcribe our
interviews
also think home appliances self-driving
cars and healthcare it's where also i
think it has most promising applications
for example in scanning or helping
radiologists identify tumors and other
cancers more accurately than humans can
now in all of the examples we've
mentioned so far the ai system is
essentially just doing one thing and
there's a label for that artificial
narrow intelligence it's really the
first stage of ai and it's where we're
at right now then there's a big leap to
the next technological frontier that's
artificial general intelligence
agi would be where the artificial
intelligence rivals human intelligence
in that it's capable of doing lots of
different things all at once the way
humans can
and in may a company called deepmind
which is owned by google said it had
taken a step in that direction
its ai model called gato was able to
carry out more than 600 tasks like play
video games search for images and use a
robotic arm to stack blocks all at the
same time
one scientist at the company said gato
means it's game over that achieving agi
is now just a matter of scaling up this
technology
one group of people thinks if we just
keep taking this approach and make these
existing systems faster and bigger you
know scale them up in essence
eventually we'll get to something that
looks like human intelligence
um i i don't really think that's the
case i think we need more breakthroughs
more conceptual breakthroughs before
we really can build systems that can
think in the way that a human being can
think and i suspect that that's probably
decades in the future now the idea that
we might one day have machines that can
think like humans raises a whole bunch
of ethical and philosophical questions
about what it could mean for society ava
go back to your room never mind the
fears about the next level after that
artificial super intelligence where the
machines go beyond human intelligence
and we start moving closer towards those
sci-fi extremes skynet has become
self-aware in one hour it will initiate
a massive nuclear attack on its enemy
but we don't need to go that far to
think about why we might want to control
ai because the technology we're using
today is already throwing up all sorts
of issues starting with privacy and
civil liberties so for example
facial recognition now creates a super
powerful tool to identify people just
through security cameras in the street
so how governments or police might use
or abuse that tech is an important
debate in russia for example police
appear to be using it to identify
anti-government protesters and the
chinese government is probably taking it
further than anyone else using facial
recognition cameras on a mass scale to
track people and monitor their behavior
there are several reports that it's also
using the technology for racial
profiling to identify uighur muslims and
tibetans
there are also big questions about bias
and discrimination so again you've got
this really powerful ai technology which
can amplify biases that already exist in
society if let's say the ai has been
trained on data that includes historical
inequalities
and there are plenty of ways that can
play out
in the us for instance a widely used
algorithm to help assess health care
needs was shown to have a built-in
racial bias
then there's the danger of design faults
or problematic assumptions about the way
that an ai system is intended to work
for example the ai system was found to
be a factor in the two plane crashes of
the boeing 737 max one in indonesia and
one in ethiopia
346 people died the autopilot was
ai-powered and it wasn't designed to
allow for a human override so it gave
dangerous nose-down commands and it
forced a plane to crash and what happens
if a self-driving car kills someone
who's responsible
there's a case going through the courts
in california right now that's dealing
with that very issue
the thing is these problems aren't
necessarily with the ai itself it's
about how it's applied how much we rely
on it and whether we're even able to
think through all the possible
consequences right now we're really
worried about things like
mistakes algorithmic mistakes not a
mistake by the computer it's a mistake
about how it was written how the code
was written and whether or not the
processes were put in place for adequate
recourse so that you can tell if
something's gone wrong the stakes get
even higher when we're talking about war
and ai being used in lethal weapons we
already have armed drones controlled by
people that use ai technology
but it's not a big stretch to get to
fully autonomous weapons so machines
making life and death decisions about
who or what to target it's probably
inevitable but it's really quite scary
you can imagine some really bad
situations happening imagine in the
taiwan strait for example having a large
group of american drones facing off
chinese drones and they're trained on
classified data how these two swarms of
drones interact and whether they might
accidentally fire at one another because
they mistake maybe some light reflecting
of a drone for an attack
that could mean that you accidentally
end up in a war or even a nuclear
conflict
proposals for an international ban on
autonomous weapons have languished at
the u.n since 2017 there has been plenty
of talking but no agreement the u.s says
it wants a non-binding code of conduct
instead of an outright ban
but it's not just the ai used in weapons
that people want to control almost every
major jurisdiction is thinking about
regulating ai in some shape or form
china's been moving fast in march it put
a pretty ambitious law in place to
regulate ai it's focused on the private
sector especially tech companies forcing
them to be transparent about how ai is
being used
the eu is working on its own set of
rules its proposals categorize ai
technology according to risk so there
there's a list of banned practices like
real-time facial recognition by police
there are high risk uses like ai being
used to hire people or to manage
essential services like electricity and
water
that kind of tech would need to follow
strict rules on transparency especially
around the software development and
testing
then there's the limited risk stuff like
spam filters and customer service bots
which would need to be clearly labeled
so that you would always know if you're
talking to a person or a machine
the eu law is still at least three years
away because there's still a long
bureaucratic process to go through but
experts say it could set a precedent for
other countries i think there are going
to be a lot of different rules and and
different governance styles and they
need to be somewhat compatible but we
also need to respect that different
societies have the right to determine
exactly how they want to trade off
security and privacy and those kinds of
things so is ai out of control well in
some ways yes the technology is moving
so fast and any meaningful regulation is
still years away but in the end ai is
not that different from other kinds of
technology it's got enormous power for
good and enormous power for bad so it's
up to us and our governments to figure
out how we want to use it
another place ai is used is in making
deep fake videos check out our episode
all about that
[Music]